avec a sévi lettres ou colis à bléneau
les envois passe depuis ce jeudi par l'
agence postale communale gardait un
service de proximité ici c'est essentiel
particulièrement pour les entreprises et
la population âgée une agence postale
dans un pays tel que notre très
important ça nous permet c'est encore un
lien avec l'administration des potes le
plus proche pour nous après c'était
saint fargeau ça nous évite des
déplacements en voiture et du gain de
temps aussi çà service public voilà on
sait à quoi faire nos impôts derrière le
guichet il y a maintenant une employée
communale forme et elle gérera cinq
jours par semaine tous les services
postaux beaucoup de courrier à franchir
des au revoir en lettre recommandée à
chaque timbre si on l'a eu
et puis 2-3 coliques sont venus déposer
seul changement pour les services
bancaires
là il faudra le plus souvent se déplacer
dans une agence classique par rapport au
bureau de poste
on a longtemps minima maximum de retrait
et de dépôt qui est 350 euros donc on
peut pas faire plus les gens doivent
signer à l'as la poste à saint fargeau
et on n'a pas d'accès aux comptes
bancaires des gens l'année dernière la
population s'était mobilisée pour sauver
son bureau de poste une pétition avait
notamment recueilli plus de 600
signatures mais avec le risque de voir
les heures d'ouverture se réduire la
municipalité a préféré reprendre la main
maintenant que j'ai mis en place s'est
ouvert donc à personne
le personnel de la mairie donc nous on
est parti pour dix huit ans la poste
versera une indemnité d'environ 1100
euros par mois à la ville en
compensation l'ancien bureau 8 devrait
être transformé en cabinet vétérinaire